je suis très chaud là je suis parti là
je vais tout je vais tout casser allez
c'est pas moi ça commence très bien
[Musique]
alors c'est parti c'est le premier
incident direct entre les États-Unis et
la Russie depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine un avion russe est entré en
collision hier avec un drone américain
au-dessus de la mer Noire
s'est craché dans la mer Chloé Barbot
Chloé alors voilà on va regarder le
sujet de de Chloé Barbeau le sujet est
en cours de transmission plus performant
au point des galets parfois les humains
voilà ce que promet tchat gpt4 la toute
nouvelle version de l'outil
d'intelligence artificielle capable de
générer du texte en droit par exemple le
programme réussite désormais l'examen
pour devenir avocat avec un score aussi
bon que les meilleurs 10%, le niveau de
son prédécesseur lui à vos idées celui
des 10% les plus faibles autre nouveauté
tchat GPT pourra aussi analyser les
images ils ont fait passer le test de QI
à l'intelligence artificielle la version
précédente 83 de QI la version actuelle
96 ça veut dire que le chat GPT gagne
trois points de QI par mois c'est pas
vrai
vous pouvez quand même parler de vos
tatouages sur scène
voilà je me suis tatoué les c'étaient
les je fais les tatouages parlent de ça
une caméra là
et en fait là je me tatoué c'est le nom
de mes doigts c'est le pouce l'index le
majeur l'annulaire et l'auriculaire
dès la première épreuve ça aurait été
bien joué je suis de garder mon calme
dans le internet là je suis dans la je
suis dans la merde
pardon faut que j'expérience
oh non
on peut y aller dans ce spectacle vous
traitez de la malbouffe Aymeric je
traite de la malbouffe ouais parce qu'à
un moment le sens d'abri ah maintenant
je dis sans abri plutôt que SDF un
moment il va se nourrir de nouilles
chinoise et en fait on a tout un truc
sur les nouilles chinoises ou il y a une
posologie sur les nouilles chinoises
c'est un bouffe plus de trois par
semaine après il y a une sorte de
bouchon qui se crée là et tout ce que tu
manges après ça descend plus voilà et
puis après tu dois faire caca par la
bouche et après tu es chroniqueurs on
touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
c'est pas le bruit de mon anus
qui était invité par Madame dalgo qui
est parti faire une sextape dans les
toilettes de la Mairie de Paris qui
imagine le niveau de la Mairie de Paris
je vais la citer parce que je vous ai
pas montré la photo c'est pas celle-là
j'ai bien pompé dans les toilettes de
l'Hôtel de Ville de Paris en tout cas et
j'ai même filmé l'Hôtel de Ville de
Paris est un lieu idéal pour un nouveau
bordel autogéré et elle donc promet de
balancer cette vidéo sur sur son site
payant une plateforme
exactement qui a mis d'autres photos
aussi à la mairie qui sont très très
sympas ah oui vu ce qui a décrit avoir
fait il fallait deux
ça serait drôle c'est que l'équipe
municipale
l'hôtel de ville ou quoi que ce soit
enfin vous trouverez ça facilement sur
les réseaux sociaux et notamment une
pause langoureuse
de Paris vous pouvez le voir on envoie
la photo voilà la vache alors on savait
que c'était le bordel à la mairie mais
pas celui-là pour le coup le syndicat du
travail sexuel qui défend les droits des
travailleurs du sexe à fustigé anidalgo
la traite en même de proxénète donc
vraiment à Paris en ce moment il y a une
super ambiance je pense que ça doit être
vraiment très très sympa
en sortant des toilettes BIM direct
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et au moins 20 ans
je vais dans la chambre quand même ah
bon c'est vrai tu l'accueilles et c'est
pour y faire quoi en principe pour
enlever la poussière vous entendez les
avions passé régulièrement c'est ça
il va falloir monter dans l'avion un
jour quand même
vous êtes en train de me draguer j'ai
chauffé la marguerite pendant tout le
jeu vous avez vu comment elle me parle
je crois que c'est une technique de
drague
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
se souvient de la première fois comme si
c'était hier ça oui quand
il y a un truc que je peux pas
directement j'étais j'avais jamais vu un
sexe
il m'a fait peur vous avez vu ça
c'est là que du lion
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu
[Rires]
[Musique]
la vie sexuelle de chacune c'est
l'affaire de chacune c'est pareil pour
les hommes mais ces personnes là qui
hypersexualisent le corps féminin et qui
viennent nous dire non mais ça c'est une
façon défendre le féminisme défendre les
femmes moi ça ça me fait vraiment vomir
quoi voilà parce qu'en réalité elle joue
le jeu des mecs parce que qui regarde
les vidéos de cette nana excusez-moi je
crois que l'essentiel de son des gens
qui la regardent et qui regardent ces
dégueulasseries c'est des mecs quel
plaisir de retrouver nos mascottes
clitoris préférés qu'on dirait qu'elles
ont pris de la drogue avec leur petit
sourire pervers mais aujourd'hui on a
découvert qu'il y avait un léger défaut
de conception alors il représente un
soldat
bah même pas même légèrement habillé il
a un peu l'épée un peu tordus
apparemment le vibrome
on pesera dès le matin
ça sera très bien on va besoin les bras
de la mascotte sont piles à la taille
pour regarder
[Musique]
on a compté cinq mains au cul et une
main au paquet qui a l'air de faire mal
la main au paquet tiens